good morning believe nation today's
message is make the world better over to
you Walt Disney I don't believe there's
a challenge anywhere in the world that's
more important to people everywhere and
finding solutions to the problems of our
cities but where do we begin how do we
start answering this great challenge
well we're convinced we must start with
the public need and the need is not just
for curing the old hills of old cities
we think the need is for starting from
scratch on virgin land and building a
special kind of new community one of the
things that I fundamentally believe is
that entrepreneurs make the world a
better place this is we are the people
that drive forward progress we are the
people that create the change and one of
the main reasons why I make these videos
and I'm so passionate helping
entrepreneurs is because you guys are
the ones is going to go out and create
that better future for for my kids and
for my grandkids and so just as a
reminder if you're struggling to I know
there's like the short-term cash flow
crunch and you want to make money now
you're trying to figure out how to
survive and survival is important but
the way to get to becoming a successful
entrepreneur is by impacting people and
some people have a big vision like Walt
Disney and want to create new cities and
other entrepreneurs have a smaller
vision and all you want to do is help
your local community and help your
customers who are buying from you but at
the core of every successful business is
a desire to do good and to make the
world a better place and so I'd
encourage you to embrace that today and
take it forward into your business so my
question the day today is how do you
make the world a better place leave it
in the comments below and I'm going to
join in this country thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events Tressa
expresso give me go I work with